your most accurate forecast though we've
got the win it's not tropical storm
force wind with its close gusts between
30 and 35 maybe 40 miles an hour in some
neighborhoods this camera is on top of
older station way out on the east side
of town looking to the west officially
where it's 60 degrees but it's cooler
than that in your neighborhood check it
out 56 for Summerlin in the lakes 57 way
up north italiano just barely at 60 down
at 7 Hills and anthem check out Ely at
27 of course you'd expect the lower 70s
in Death Valley but even Reno just
barely above the freezing mark so we're
gonna go for a high of 80 today when
we'd normally be pushing a hundred low
this morning 12 degrees below normal so
we got a big warm-up that's coming
because this area of high pressure is
gonna kick all this stuff out of here in
the meantime for your family and friends
across the nation storminess up over the
northern tier of states and again now
tropical depression Cristobal trust ORMs
surge warnings have replaced all the
tropical storm warnings are talking
about 6-feet waves now we're talking
about additional rainfall through
central and northern Mississippi and
Alabama six to eight inches of new
rainfall Wow okay here is your seven-day
forecast and it's a lot nicer especially
when you consider a 10 degree jump to 90
tomorrow from 80 today 96 closer to
normal Wednesday will top triple digits
for Thursday and for Friday but take a
look later in the week more wind comes
in later Friday into Saturday which will
drop high temperatures down into the mid
90s